Hello. Welcome back to Portainer in production.
Today, we're gonna take a look at running
and using Portainer on Kubernetes
to manage Kubernetes.
Before we get into the fun stuff, we
have to get Portainer installed to our Kubernetes
cluster. There are two ways to do so.
One, with Helm.
Two, with customize. Let's take a look at
both approaches now.
So the first thing I'll say is the
documentation on Portainer's website is fantastic. So if
you ever get stuck or need some help,
feel free to drop into the comment section,
but also go check the docs.
The the docs will tell you that you
have to ensure you have a default storage
class available in your cluster.
You have to check there's a default storage
class available within your cluster. Why? Well, because
Portainer has state. Both the Helm chart and
the customized approach to the installation will provision
a persistent volume claim which must be satisfied
before Portainer will ever get healthy. In order
to check if you have a default storage
class, run kubectl get
s c or autocomplete it to storage classes.
What you're looking for here is, well, anything
on this list is a good start. For
Docker desktop, you'll see something like host path,
and we need to ensure that we have
default and parenthesis.
This just means that we don't need to
provide a storage class name when we provision
or request a persistent volume claim with the
cluster. Next up,
we do a helm install.
You click on deploy with helm, you'll see
that you have to do a helm repository
add pertainer and point it to the helm
chart repository
and a helm repo update.
If you're unsure, you can run helm repo
list to see a retainer
is there.
Main already exists.
If you're not sure when you last added
it, run a helm repo update to ensure
that you have all the latest versions cached
locally.
The documentation
suggests you do a helm install.
I'm going to suggest that you don't do
that and instead modify the command to be
a helm upgrade to dash dash install just
like I have here.
This just means that this item potent. You
can run this command over and over and
over again and any changes via your values.
Yaml will be reflected
in the cluster.
Help install can only ever be run once.
Next,
everything else is the same as the docs.
We're passing create namespace and the namespace of
Portainer.
This just means that this Helm release will
live in the Portainer namespace.
And if it doesn't exist, hey, it'll create
it.
Next, we give our Helm release a name.
We're calling ours Portainer.
I know. Surprised. Right? Next, we provide the
helm chart repository name and to helm chart
itself name.
That is Portainer slash Portainer.
Lastly, we provide them one flag and that
is dash dash set which will set TLS
force to true.
This just means that we're telling Portainer to
only run and expose and listen on the
TLS
port.
Let's quit this
and run deploy.
As you can see, my helm upgrade dash
dash install detects that the release doesn't exist
and deploys it for the first time. We
then get some notes that tell us how
to get the IP address and port for
our Portainer instance,
but we're not going to use that. Instead,
let's take a look at what happened in
our cluster.
We can run kubectl, send the namespace to
our Portainer and run get deploy and get
pods
at the same time.
You'll see we have one deployment called Portainer,
which has one of one ready and of
course that has a pod,
which is one of one ready.
Things look pretty good.
Now on the documentation for the Portainer deploy,
you'll see that I'm on the default tab
of node port. We also have ingress and
load balancer available.
These just require extra set parameters
that modify the helm deploy.
Now when should you use node port versus
ingress versus load balancer? Well,
if you're just kicking the tires on Portainer
with Kubernetes locally using Docker desktop or Colima
or anything else, you're always going to use
NodePort.
Well, more than likely. Why?
Well, the chances are you won't have an
ingress controller set up within your cluster. Ingress
controllers are not installed by default unless you're
using a managed Kubernetes instance.
You have to choose between running Contour, Emissary,
Traffic, NGINX, or one of the many other
ingress controllers available on the market.
So if you're unsure, go with NodePort. If
you're pushing your container into a production environment,
then you probably don't want to use NodePort.
NodePort is just a nice hacky way to
get it working quickly.
From there, you will want to work with
your platform team, your SRE team, your DevOps
team, or maybe it's just you, but ensure
that you have an ingress controller
and configure it appropriately.
And then the last one is load balancer.
This is a quick way if you're running
Kubernetes in a managed environment like GKE, AKS,
or EKS.
However, please note every load balancer you provision
or every service of type load balancer typically
gets a new load balancer as part of
the cloud provider. That's usually cost you a
minimum of $20 per month per load balancer,
so the cost can add up really quickly.
It's actually more typical to have a single
load balancer service as part of your ingress
controller deployment and then handle everything else via
ingress objects.
So pick wisely.
Let's jump back to our command line.
Now, we can run kubectl
get
service and of course and our Portainer namespace.
We'll see here that we have our node
port service. It has a cluster IP and
we have a few mappings. The one that
we are more interested in
is this 30779.
This maps to the pertainer TLS port of
9443.
We can now open up localhost on that
port
and ensure that you use the right protocol
HTTPS.
Now we never told Portainer to use cert
manager or less incorrect or anything else for
TLS. That means we're getting a self signed
certificate.
For that, you'll need to click advanced and
proceed.
From here, we can configure our first Portainer
user, the admin user. We've already covered that
in a previous video, so I'm not going
to go into that again now.
So what if you do want to tweak
the default helm installation?
Well, you can go to github.com/protainer/kates.
That's k8s.
From here, you'll find there's a charts retainer
directory.
As with every Helm chart, there's a values
dot YAML. You can click the raw button
and copy and paste it locally or hit
download.
I already have the default values file here.
This is where you begin to make your
modifications for your own helm installation.
You can use the enterprise edition or the
business edition.
This is free for up to five nodes.
So take advantage of it. Go to the
Portainer website, click business edition, and get your
free license.
Now all of the image, image pool secrets,
node selector, service accounts, service is pretty standard
stuff, and it's unlikely that you'll want to
modify that except in extreme
and niche circumstances.
If you wish to provide your own TLS
certificate, you can do so using an existing
secret.
This is great if you have cert manager
in your cluster and you've already got that
speaking acme to less encrypt, and you have
a real production x five zero nine certificate
you can use. If you want to enable
any of Portainer's feature flags, you can add
them to this string here.
And if you want to go the ingress
route, you can configure the ingress here.
For reference,
when we're on the documentation
and you see deploy via ingress, these set
flags directly correlate
to all of the values in the YAML.
You don't need both. You only have to
do it once.
Assuming you're using Contour as your ingress controller,
you can set the ingress class name
to
contour.
And if you're going down the ingress route,
remember to set your host here, portainer.myorg.com.
If you want to set resource limits or
constraints or minimum allocations,
you could do so here in the resources
block.
And lastly, the persistence. 10 gig is probably
enough for most installations, but if you need
more, feel free to tweak that here.
If you have more than one storage class
available, remember to set that here
too.
And if you have an existing claim
because of some backup or restore process, which
we'll cover at another video very soon, then
you can add your existing claim name here
too. So the Helm chart provides all the
configuration options that you need to fit most
use cases.
Enjoy.
So
while Helm is great, you may prefer to
use kubectl
with customize. It just means there's no state
in your cluster and with customized being embedded
in kubectl, you don't even need an extra
command.
On the Portainer documentation, we can see that
they provide a kubectl command
that allows us to deploy Portainer.
This is nice because it's versioned
and we have good control over upgrades too.
So let's take a look at how we
modify or tweak the versioned Portainer manifest using
customize.
The first thing you're gonna wanna do is
create a customization dot YAML.
This looks and feels like any other Kubernetes
resource and that we have to provide an
API version and a kind.
Next, we can add any resources that we
want to deploy as part of this customization.
It supports local and remote resources. So here,
we're actually able to put in the URL
for the Portainer managed and versioned
release artifact. That's pretty sweet. Now customize offers
a lot of ways for you to make
tweaks, and I would encourage you to go
and check out their documentation.
The link is in the description. But we're
gonna take a look at two relatively simple
augmentations that we can make to the YAML.
One, it's quite common to add extra labels
to third party resources so that people know
who is responsible for them. What are the
SLAs?
Who to call when something goes wrong? So
here,
we're going to add
a new set of key value pairs. One,
app my org.
Two,
env rocks.
Does it make any sense? No.
Will it work for this example?
Definitely. Lastly,
we want to add or use a set
of patches
to modify resources.
So let's take a look at that patch
file. Customization patches have to match a resource
and then changes will be diffed. Here, we're
matching apps v one deployment
and the Portainer namespace where the deployment is
called Portainer.
On this resource,
we're going to find a container called Portainer,
and we're going to add or edit the
memory resource limit
and set it to 512
meg.
So now we can kubectl
apply
using dash k to tell it to use
the embedded customize and the kubectl command. Again,
you don't need an extra tool to start
using customize today.
And we pass in the directory
to any Kubernetes resources and customization object that
we wish to apply.
Here, we can see all of the resources
that we expect were created.
So let's see and confirm the changes we
requested have been made.
We can describe our namespace,
Portainer.
And you'll actually see our labels app, my
org, and rocks exist.
Not only that, we can describe the deployment.
And on this deployment, we will see labels
at my org
and rocks.
Not just on the labels,
also on the selector
and the pod template.
Perfect.
Lastly,
our pod called Portainer with a container called
Portainer
now has a memory limit of 512
meg. Sweet.
So now that we are in our Portainer
instance, we can click home
and we can see all of our environments
here. Now because
our Kubernetes and Portainer server are all the
same place. They're all the same thing. We've
got our local environment, which is the Kubernetes
cluster that Portainer is running on.
When you click on that,
you know, we have all the basic things
you would expect from a UI on top
of Kubernetes.
That would be the ability to check out
our namespaces,
the ability to see all of the applications
running on our cluster,
and we can drill down
to inspect individual applications.
Like so. We have the ability to view
and edit our config maps and secrets
and any volumes available within the cluster.
We also have the ability to add
Helm repositories
and deploy Helm charts
with a very nice user interface.
Assuming we want to deploy cert manager,
we can select the namespace that we want
to run it,
give it a name,
and if you want to pass any custom
values,
they're all presented
like so.
If you're happy with that, you hit install.
Helm has never been this easy.
But I don't just want to show you
the UI on top of Kubernetes.
Instead, I want to show you how Portainer
brings the same ideology of simplifying complex things
to the cluster itself. So let's pop open
the cluster settings and go to setup.
From here, we can allow people to provision
cloud load balancers
if we want. We can turn on
change windows.
We can configure the time or time frame
that we allow rollouts to happen. We can
restrict access to the default namespace
and ensure that only administrators
deploy ingresses, you know, resources that allow external
access to workloads within the cluster. But that's
still not what I want to focus on.
Instead,
I want to take a look at security
constraints.
Here, we can enable pod security constraints. And
before I turn any of these policies on,
let's just hit save.
So what is this doing in the background?
Well, let's jump over to our CLI and
take a look. You'll see the last command
I ran was to list our namespaces.
So let's run that again.
And what you'll see is that seventeen seconds
ago, we have a gatekeeper system namespace added.
We can use this namespace
and see what's running on our cluster.
And you'll see we we have the gatekeeper
controller manager
and the audit pods working. Now it doesn't
matter if you're not familiar with what gatekeeper
is, but it is in our cluster and
managed for us by Portainer. So let's go
back up and take a look at some
of these constraints. We can restrict privileged containers
from our cluster. We can restrict sharing the
process ID namespace and the host IPC namespace.
We can make sure that no workloads
mount host file system paths,
the host path directive.
But if you want to allow access to
some,
you can read only or writable. You can
require that all workloads have a read only
root file system. You can restrict escalation to
root privileges,
restrict Linux capabilities,
allowing
Capsys admin
an absolutely terrible idea.
But if you're familiar with capabilities,
you can have a low list and drop.
You can have allowed capabilities and required drop
capabilities.
Lastly,
we have the ability to enable AC Linux,
App Armor, SecComp,
and SIS control profiles. But for now, let's
just turn on the few that we've selected,
and it's done. We come back to our
gatekeeper.
We'll see that not much has changed.
But if we run kubectl get validating
web configurations,
we can see gatekeeper is here. And what's
actually happening is the gatekeeper is listening for
every resource that is applied to the cluster.
And if it violates any of the policies,
it'll be denied. You can run kubectl
API resources
and grip
for gatekeeper.
And from this list, we can see that
we have access to all of the gatekeeper
custom resources,
whether that be configs, allowed users, capabilities,
file system groups, host file systems, and so
forth and so forth. We also have access
because we enabled these in the Portainer UI,
the ability to describe constraint templates
for the KATE's PSP host file system,
which if you scroll up, will actually reveal
all the Ragel that was used as an
emission policy
to deny
host path volumes
on any of your workloads.
And I don't think there's ever been an
easier way to secure a Kubernetes cluster than
this one page on the Portainer UI. So
that's it for today's video. We take a
look at the two ways to install Portainer
to a Kubernetes cluster, allowing modifications and tweaks
based on your own requirements. From there, we
dove in the Portainer UI.
Of course, it offers all the same features
you'd expect from a Kubernetes UI,
the ability to browse and navigate the resources
within a cluster. But Portainer brings an air
of simplicity
with a UI that just wants to help
you get things done.
Securing a Kubernetes cluster through installing
gatekeeper,
rating Regal,
importing
policies.
It's quite a challenge, but not with Portainer.
So go check it out and make your
lives a little bit easier. We'll back soon
for the rest of Portainer in production. Have
a great day.